daniel bilalian est ce que finalement il
est arrivé dans l'histoire des jeux que
des politiques empire vraiment bénéfices
pense à tony blair pour londres
est ce que est ce que c'est un plus un
atout pour finalement le temps le fait
effectivement du décalage que souligné
judith entre la date d'être en amont et
en aval rarement parce que en général ça
se termine sur le plan financier de
manière assez désastreuse non jusqu'à
présent j'ai pas le souvenir d'un homme
politique qui ait tiré vraiment les
bénéfices des jo selon la tradition des
jeux olympiques c'est une joie éphémère
quand même je veux pas avoir l'air de
celui qui veut pas danser en rond avec
tout le monde mais je pense que les
choses vont se compliquer à partir
d'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui nous avons été
nommés enfin nous avons pas été nommé si
je vous dis ce que je pense vraiment
c'est que les américains ont renoncé
si les américains avaient voulu la
puissance pour près du seuil ou ne
serait ce que par les sponsors ibm
coca-cola sont les américains qui ont
décidé de faire de 1028 alors on peu
surjouée la victoire de paris pendant
péché mais mais en fait si nous avons
les jeux olympiques c'est parce que nos
amis américains ont accepté d'attendre
quatre années de plus